[Music]
6 26 on your Monday morning you know
there's a viewer out there who missed
the responses to that long-running
driving you crazy email chain Ruth
writes hey I never heard the answers
when somebody asked why at a stoplight
do some people let a space of one to two
cars happen in front of them Ruth says I
could drive sideways through some of
these nuts well Ruth uh I get more
emails about this than almost everything
else besides Speeders slow drivers in
the fast lane and cars with expired or
no tags
most of the responses though were along
the lines of one car length between cars
is a safety precaution I've been
rear-ended don't want to slam into the
car in front of me viewer Brad expanded
on the financial implications say a car
hits you from behind causing you to hit
the person in front of you making you
buy him a new car and who knows if the
guy that hit you has Insurance to fix
your car or your front person's car do
you have thousands of dollars to buy the
guy in front a car and pay 70 grand for
their medical bills Terry who says I'm
not a psychologist theorized that it
could be a subconscious transference of
drivers social distancing
we'll close with Linda who may be nailed
it on why the Wide Open Spaces in a
hurry to stop and text everyone's head
looking down at their crotch at a signal
okay Ruth thank you for writing in now
we've got links to all of those earlier
stories in the online version of this
story just visit our website click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully and please put on that
phone feel free to chime in on this
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com